[Music]
do
[Music]
happy thursday welcome to the group chat
presented by bleach
presented by then to a live in the
future report app we appreciate you guys
checking in and tapping in every week
uh to get your picks your three by twos
and your hoodies
special guest alert from the
we yeah aaron k dolan from fanduel round
of applause for aaron k
dolan
[Music]
thanks for having me on we have of
course of course
falcon we have the winter soldier and
now we have captain marvel welcome
so um what kind of vibes are you
bringing today erin
i feel like you can only say positive
vibes i mean i'm super excited to talk
about some betting and hopefully i bring
you some good vibes in terms of winning
some bets tonight
yes yes yes yes i'm so happy it was that
was the key i'm so happy you said
good vibes aaron i'm so happy i learned
from you gabby nice i'm so happy
yeah so what we've learned this week
is that charles barkley unveiled a new
golf swing at a pro-am
in birmingham alabama and it's actually
correlated to his recent performance
in chuck versus america every week we go
head-to-head with the legend
charles barkley and the chuckster put a
w
on the board last time out so america we
are 11 and four and the chuckster
is nine and six he's only two games
behind us
we're going head-to-head with charles
barkley again
two of the game's coldest will be
sizzling in dallas tonight
earlier today we asked you on twitter
who will score more points
luca doncic or kevin durant that was the
twitter
poll twitter poll what are the results
let's see those oh kevin durant 62
18. america is boating with
with kd in their last 10 games both luca
doncic
and kevin durant are averaging 29 points
so we should see some fireworks today
g-money um
i know we know that how the twitter
audience they feel a certain way leaning
with kd
but what about what are the commenters
which way are they leaning
either katie or luca tonight
let me ask them kathy let me ask them
hey everybody in the comments everybody
that's filling up the comments they are
they're going they're going today all
right uh you guys let me know who's
going to score more points
luca or kevin durant but aaron
welcome to the show once again how do
you feel about
charles barkley betting skills i mean
he's a philly guy so i have to respect
him i'm from philadelphia of course but
i'm a huge fan of him but his picks i
mean
the numbers kind of speak for themselves
nine and six america eleven and four he
got the win last week but
we'll see if he gets it this week so uh
aaron who do you have in this matchup do
you have kd
or do you have luca doncic kd
all the way i mean he put up 42 points
and then 32 points against the bucks
respectively i mean put this in
perspective
in the last 20 games that luca has
played in he's only hit over 32 points
in three of those games
kd all the way plus he'll be extra
motivated given that the nets just
dropped their last three games
this is gonna be a tough assignment for
dorian finney smith
and uh the canadian dwight powell
because kevin durant is virtually
unguardable to your point aaron uh and
this is going against my better judgment
but i'm going with luka doncic
for two motivation motivational factors
one he's playing on his home court
and two the dallas mavericks have to win
every game to avoid
a first-round matchup with the los
angeles lakers
and that offense is squarely on luca's
shoulders i think he puts on a show
tonight
give me luca doncic i know the the odds
are
minus 130 minus 132. i know he's the
favorite
give me that g money um the audience
the audi the audience on twitter is
riding with kd aaron is riding with kd
who are our commenters riding with
cabbie aaron let's hear it then the
people at home
this right here is the handy dandy ipad
this is how
you get your hoodies and i'm in the
handy dandy ipad
giving away hoodies uh i just want to
get this off off first
ava goat you are not getting the hoodie
you do not spam the comments that's not
a way for you to get the hoodie brother
do not spam the comments richie 21 says
kevin durant joe yan says america is
wrong
jesse bolano says luca jesse bolano says
luca shout out to you jesse bellanos
johnny ball game says uh
luca shout out to you johnny blog 56
mayo 5681 says durant is the man
shout out to everybody that i said you
are walking away
with a hoodie um so who do you
that being said i see a lot of luca i
see a lot of luca cabbie i see i see a
lot of luca
um unfortunately i'm going to have to
disagree with the audience
i'm going to have to disagree with the
comments there isn't many times that i
disagree with the comments captain
you don't disagree with the commenters
so you you know that
but but the reason is the reason is
kevin durant he's the best player in the
league when he's helped
so i would never i would never bet
against kevin durant
plus money plus money in any situation
if i got kd getting plus money give it
to me bro that is a
massive asterisk when he's healthy you
realize the guy missed like
almost half the season this year right
yeah i
i do and and he's been resting up and i
think that he's back
i think that he's back he's been bawling
and when he's out there cabbie
come on cabbie when he's out there you
cannot tell me that that man does not be
balling yeah
of course obviously yes and i know that
he's gonna he's gonna put a lot of
pressure
on dallas's defense i'm just all right
so listen
we have to find out during the iconic
pregame show the iconic inside the nba's
pregame show
to find out if charles barkley is riding
with aaron
and g money or riding with me and the
audience
with luka doncic or kevin durant so make
sure to tap
in at uh i believe it's 7 p.m eastern on
tnt
the best things in life are free
laughter
ridicule from your friends and free
money from fanduel the 3x2 is still
scorching across the bedding the betting
sphere and as the
like the homie kelly stewart loves to
say fanduel is giving away
free money the bet is very simple will
there be
two three pointers made in the first
three minutes of a game
that is the three by two last time out
we locked in
dallas versus golden state and this is
what happened
[Music]
actually steph hit five all right
cleveland two stephen five
thank you very much uh generally
whenever whenever cabbie i have to make
a public service announcement and aaron
i want your take on this
whenever 30 is on the court
please take the yes the 3x2 was going to
happen whatever 30 is on the court
yeah yeah right aaron right thank you
thank you i just i just needed i just
needed some type of backing
here yeah exactly exactly because you
know cabbie always
i'll i'll never mind go ahead kevin wait
you need you need a vibe check right now
gee buddy
cabbie you always throw salt you always
bring up the raptors warriors thing you
know you do man yeah
and kyle 26
so aaron um uh
sorry no there's a which one which one
this is to the audience
excuse me which game should we lock in
brooklyn versus dallas
or the lakers versus the clippers
g-money
we know that there are so many volume
shooters in
either game so who are the volume
shooters in the comments section
and who which game do they want to lock
in
cabbie let me talk to him let me talk to
him real quick people in the audience
people that are watching
people that are in the comments which
game should we ride should we ride
dallas and brooklyn or should we ride
the two la teams
for today's three by two you guys let me
know but aaron
what is your take on the three by two do
you like this bet in general
yeah of course i love the bet i mean you
get that immediate action that
excitement beginning in the game
instead of having to wait to see if your
bet even hits by the end of the game i
mean
the first score basket lots of fun you
can bet that on the fanduel sportsbook
but this is an
awesome opportunity to have about three
minutes of excitement and try to get
those two three-pointers there but i
absolutely love this bet lots of fun
hey salute to you aaron for appearing on
an ig live with g-money in the past
watching it three by two uh so tonight
which game
which game do you prefer the dallas
versus brooklyn or the lakers versus
clippers for the 3x2
definitely brooklyn and dallas i mean
lots of stars there you have luka fourth
and league in scoring kyrie irving 10th
i think brooklyn just shoots lights out
in order to get those wins anyways
so they're going to come out guns are
blazing and obviously those you know
three straight losses for the nets i
think they're just going to come out hot
and obviously
on the maverick side you have players
like luca doncic who can obviously hit
those threes pretty quickly
i'm right there with you with brooklyn
and dallas because neither team is known
for defense so we expect this to be a
high scoring game
and the fireworks as soon as they hit
the court
exactly and and dallas is playing with a
lot of uh confidence right now they've
won seven of their last 10 games
and tim hardaway jr had 10
three-pointers
in his last game give me all that sauce
dallas
versus brooklyn uh g-money which three
by two are we riding with which which
three by two does the the audience
uh wanna lock in tonight cabbie let me
get
my my uh handy dandy ipad uh out
i got jess bolanos i already gave you a
hoodie but shout out to you again he
says
aaron gets it he says aaron gets it she
does gets it i i like to pick thank you
uh sir nick's serge nick wang says
ride to dallas brooklyn for the three by
two
i like that dallas i like that sir um
s stein l johnson 23 s tyne l
johnson 23 is he gave me the luca gift
so therefore i'm assuming that he's
rocking with brooklyn versus dallas
shout out to you s stein uh you're
walking away with a hoodie
uh cabbie i'm done here all right i'm
done here
i'm done in the comments uh is that the
game that you're rocking with you guys
the the i'm rocking with you guys yeah i
feel like i'm i'm rocking with you guys
brooklyn two games brooklyn yeah
brooklyn dallas they're shooters
all around the court you guys mentioned
uh you know how i feel about the
brooklyn nights cabbie and kd
when he's on the court i i think the
three by two's money i feel like you
guys can argue back and forth about this
for the rest of the show
i feel like keep going
we can keep going we can keep going
uh because kd's the best player when
he's on the court
slow down slow down all right
check out our vr betting socials for the
link to the 3x2 offered by
fanduel brooklyn in both nba team sorry
brooklyn and both
la teams are stacked with all nba talent
and eight of the last
nine nba finals mvps
are on the squads that's kd that's braun
and that's kawhi
uh they've been the betting favorites to
win the nba championship
since basically december but the more
interesting race
is all the pressure on the teams trying
to get into the playing tournament
and win single elimination games so will
these five teams make the playoffs let's
take a look at the odds here
charlotte golden state indiana
san antonio washington interestingly
enough
all plus money on the yeses g-money i
know your
your army is filled with underdogs are
are any
any teams that surprise you that are
getting love in the comments
it's interesting also that it's all plus
money for the yeses
cabbie let me let me team up a little
bit let me team up and ask them
uh guys people that are in the comments
which team
has the best value to make the playoffs
which team has the best value
to make the playoffs aaron i have to
talk to you we love
teams that are dogs we love teams with
value which
team are you betting on to get the
seventh or eighth seed
from this board i think the wizards have
absolutely the best value plus 184 right
now in the fanduel
book i mean russell westbrook bradley
beal amazing duo heating up at the right
time
westbrook has a league leading 33 triple
doubles this season including five in
the last six games
they've been heating up like i mentioned
just i mean i understand last
night they lost by one point to the
bucks but still they've been great
against the spread which is just an
added bonus
for people like us 12-0 and two in the
last 14 games
they played the raptors tonight but good
value for the wizards to make the
playoffs i like that at the plus money
right now
again on the fanduel sportsbook aaron
i'm not saying this because you're the
guest
and i just want to agree with the guest
because i'm uh
we're a hospitable host but i agree with
you
[Laughter]
but i agree with you with washington
like yeah
westbrook like he's not playing like a
dude who's had four knee surgeries
he's playing like he's pissed off and he
is a bad
man he is about to pass the great oscar
robertson for all-time
uh all-time triple doubles bradley beal
is still the
um the league's leading scorer and
washington is cooking right now they've
you said they've uh 12 and two or or
something like that
um so i i i like i don't think anybody
wants to see
washington in the playoffs because
gimme russell and gimme bradley beal in
a single elimination game
that that's what i'm locking in i'm also
going to jump on that plus 184 on
fanduel so
that's my pick i'm right there locking
lockstep with you aaron
uh g money uh other than your golden
state warriors
do you like one of these other teams on
the board to make the uh make the
playoffs
why does it have to be other than my
goals
in those situations thank you aaron
exactly thank you aaron steph is scary
in a single game elimination
uh yeah in the seal game elimination
game he's scary
why wouldn't you want to face i mean why
wouldn't you want steph curry on the
court
why wouldn't you bet the golden state
warriors they're plus 110 for a reason
their yes was the
the lowest value for a reason cabbie
listen that's why i would bet the golden
state warriors how are you going to bet
on
exactly exactly
look at aaron aaron knows he he's smart
he feeds him he might be in the locker
room he might be
he aon but but when it comes off cabbie
and the lights shine
when it's game time 30 performs
30 performs and i guarantee you i
guarantee you any other team
lining up against 30 in the golden state
warriors in a single elimination game
they gonna be shaking in their boots
because them golden
from time to time my dude okay you don't
always wear the same pair of sneakers
you don't always wear the same hoodie
you don't always wear the same you don't
always eat the same pizza okay
you could chain you can mix in some
different uh different
picks and vibes every once in a while
when's the last time i better like i
talked about the warrior i talked about
we
talk about steph curry all the time yeah
i talk about steph curry
all the time the warriors i don't i'm
gonna be honest
as a team huh but we have steph curry
though
and in a single game of limit in a
single game elimination game
i like my chances with 30 on my side
well let's let's keep it moving
to two other players who've been
scorching the nba in the last week luca
doncic
put up a russell westbrook type of
triple double
30 points 20 assists 12 rebounds against
russell westbrook's
wizards and as aaron mentioned earlier
in the show katie dropped a couple of 40
pieces uh
recently so these are monster numbers
that these guys are putting up but
monster numbers are rarely seen
on greg's same game parlays the numbers
have been
a little bit like this so let's see okay
let's see last week's ticket
and aaron i'm not i'm not sure i'm not
sure if you're a bad boss
i mean okay that vibe's in the comments
12 to one on the on the same game
do you want to give us 10 seconds made
oh yeah you know i was going to do that
you know i was going to do that aaron
i mean you see he delivered you see he
delivered he came through three out of
five i can't really fault you there i
mean that wasn't that bad
that's what hey aaron didn't need to
have it
but i mean three out of five kids we we
might need to have you on more because
you are bringing all the good vibes need
good vibes in the comments
send me sunsets giving away hoodies uh
sit sitting all type of sunsets hold on
hold on three and four three three out
of five cavi three out of five
if you if you would have single bet all
of those plus money bro no
no they wouldn't have been plus money
because some of those are like minus 400
minus 700. that's why the ticket was
only 12 to 1 my dude
but anyway let's let's
bring it back some positive vibes okay
all right
i also need to um mention that three out
of five is only good in baseball
not good on the same game parley uh
aaron what
what are your rules for build before we
get to greg's ticket this week what are
your rules
for building parlays do you take a lot
of favorites
and have you know have low odds on a
five to one
or do you take some long shots and make
that payday
a lot fatter i mean i feel like the
point of having a parlay is to have the
payday be as high as possible so i mean
i
obviously look at all the important
trends i look at the injury report and
take everything into account but i
definitely don't just take all the
favorites because i'll tell you there
are some parlays where i've had four
legs and they're all underdogs
and they hit and i've had some parlays
that are four favorites and
all four will lose so i'm a big
proponent of going for those underdogs
especially
in the parlays you hear that g-money
underdogs is the worst feeling
they're supposed to be favored and they
all lose it's very defeating
i i just i just want wins cabbie i i
just want to win
uh wins win yeah winners only man that's
that's that's what i stand for
uh and i'm afraid you you you don't fit
the bill but that's okay
that's okay cabbie because we're gonna
uh we're gonna talk about this
this uh same game parlay we're starting
off with brooklyn we're starting it off
with brooklyn
um we're gonna take brooklyn minus three
and a half i do not know why this line
is minus three and a half
i thought it would be something like
minus six maybe five and a half
give me three and a half brooklyn uh and
then we're gonna
we're gonna go over to the over we're
gonna go over to the total and take the
over
see this as a high scoring game we've
been talking about kd
we've been talking about luca we've been
talking about these teams not playing
defense so uh
why not lean e over and i just mentioned
katie so let me pull up the graphics so
we can
show the people what katie's gonna do
today uh
the graphic the graphic pull the kd
graphic up
over 30 points yeah okay there it is
yeah there it is
kevin durant to go over 30 points uh
he's gonna have a big game today i think
it's going to be a back and forth with
him and luca
and with that being said cabbie that's
going to lead me into the next one luca
yes yes hey shout out to the control
room they pulled it up
luca 30 points back and forth affair
yes going to be a lot of points and then
cavi to round it off
kevin durant does this in his sleep he
does this in his sleep katie
go give me two give me two
three-pointers
that's it katie that's all i need round
this part parlay off
and uh i'm feeling real good about this
one uh
honestly cabbie this is the uh the most
the best i've ever felt about one of
these same game parlays
you've had something so this is the it's
nine to one bro
the last ticket was three and a half say
that i totally agree with the nets minus
three and a half given that they're 4-0
against as far in their last four games
it's a favorite 7-0 against the score in
the last seven thursday games so
i'm all over the brooklyn that's my
three and a half as well aaron
i appreciate your good vibes you kind of
like you see that cabbie
do you do you see the vibes like no
they're thank you
before we jumped on the show 90 of the
money and 85
of the bets are on brooklyn to cover as
well so i think the public also agrees
with you
okay but listen the public was on
phoenix yesterday too
to the tune of like 90 percent and they
got the door blown off by atlanta so we
can't always trust the public
um but g-money yeah yeah you're right no
i know you definitely made the
public i'm just trying to make greg feel
a little better about his partner thank
you
thank you we're this is a group chat
like this we're team
okay okay kd my my only
beef with the with the ticket is katie
30 plus points
how many minutes is this dude going to
play he is efficient
but if this dude only plays 24 26
28 minutes i don't know if that 30 plus
is gonna hit that's
they need to win though i feel like
you're going to play him as much as he
can
can you just mention he's one of the
most efficient one of the most
efficient players well if katie puts it
up
it's usually going to go in i mean based
off his numbers so
all right well listen good luck good
luck as always and uh we have to salute
aaron
kate dolan for joining the group chat
thank you so much for
being with us and making greg feel
better about his same game parley where
can people thank you
thank you where can people find you hey
we'll continue today
i promise you i promise you i promise
you if i win this one
it's the vibes it is the vibes aaron was
just sending all type of good vibes
cabbie uh i don't know man okay well
uh the vibes are a little bit different
so so hopefully
hopefully they bring you some luck but
aaron where can people find your picks
uh some of your bad beats if you
experience them and
and your content on the socials all my
content will be posted on social media
at aaron kate dolan across
all social media so you can find some of
my picks there and i post a lot of
videos and stuff so hopefully they will
help you guys
all right i'm going to be tailing some
of your baseball picks and your
basketball ones so
make them good remember what you learned
today no pressure erin no problem
cabbie wait wait wait wait before we get
out of here handy dandy ipad let me get
away
enrique enrique brenes shout out to you
you're walking away with a hoodie
angelito vasquez it's a lifestyle shout
out to you you were walking away with a
hoodie
uh dave dave ew 3156
says never bet against kevin durant i
love that i love that take
joe says no more hoodies joe i am right
here
i am right here giving away hoodie shout
out to you you're walking away sir nick
wang i think you have one already but if
you don't you're walking away with
hoodie greg money sniper
yes
benny j88 greg's is a fax machine
because all i do is
print out facts do i need to keep going
kevin
38 grant to the moon greg to the moon
lock me in
hey everybody i said you're walking away
with hoodie go ahead kevi i'm sorry
we know why you like kevin durant
because you got a bunch of burner
accounts in the comment section bro i
see what you're doing
hey cabbie those people are real i
promise you they're real man all right
uh
remember they're real remember what you
learned today g-money's got burner
accounts in the comments section giving
themselves
there are two three by twos tonight
brooklyn and dallas in la versus l.a so
lock them in
and we love the washington wizards to
make the playoffs so
uh alongside aaron k dog and the
warriors and the warriors
and greg ivory my name is gabby richards
we are leaving the group chat take care
guys
good luck bye guys
[Music]
[Music]
you